nouvelle salle de sanctions de l'union
européenne contre la junte militaire en
birmanie
nous avons adopté un deuxième train de
sanctions beaucoup plus important qui
touche 10 personnes et deux entités
économiques appartenant à l'armée est
une fois de plus évident que l'aide
humanitaire à la population birmane doit
être augmenté nous avons décidé de
l'augmenter de 9 millions d'euros
mais l'important est de mettre fin à la
répression en mars lui avait déjà imposé
des sanctions contre 11 personnes et au
pouvoir un embargo sur les ventes
d'armes à destination de la birmanie a
également été décrété des sanctions
contre certains membres de l'état-major
birmans ont aussi été maintenu
l'objectif condamné la répression
violente des manifestations
antigouvernementales qui perdure dans le
pays depuis le coup d'état du 1er
février
nous avons entamé le processus de mise
en oeuvre de nouvelles sanctions contre
la junte militaire ainsi que certains
individus et deux conglomérats
économique soutenue par l'armée que nous
sanctionnons l'armée birmane devrait
accepter les offres de dialogue et
profiter de la réunion de l'asian du 24
avril pour montrer sa volonté de trouver
les moyens de sortir de cette crise un
sommet à jakarta en indonésie auquel la
junte devraient prendre part
de leur côté le secrétaire général de
l'onu antonio guterres est c'est son
prédécesseur ban ki moon appelle ce
lundi-là zean agir en faveur d'une issue
pacifique de cette crise au moins sept
cent trente sept personnes ont été tuées
et plus de 3000 arrêtées selon
l'association d'assistance aux
prisonniers politiques
[Musique]